FOREIGN OUTRAGE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
LAST NIGHT, I TOLD YOU THAT I
THOUGHT THE WHITE HOUSE MADE A
RATHER UNFORTUNATE DECISION
GIVING ABC ANCHOR GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS TWO DAYS WORTH OF
ACCESS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AFTER TRAVELING ON AIR FORCE ONE
TO IOWA, THE FORMER BILL CLINTON
CALMS DIRECTOR CHILLED WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
WHERE HE FOUND HE IS ONLY
POSSIBLE VERTICAL INCH ADVANTAGE
OVER THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
>> IF FOREIGNERS, CHINA, RUSSIA,
SOMEONE ELSE OFFERS INFORMATION
ON AN OPPONENT, SHOULD THEY
ACCEPT IT OR CALL THE FBI?
>> I THINK YOU MAY BE TO BOTH.
I THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LISTEN, THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH LISTENING.
IF I THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING
WRONG I WOULD MAYBE GO TO THE
FBI IF I THOUGHT THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, TRUMP OFF
THE CUFF SEEMS TO BE MORE LIKE
KIND OF A FLICK OFF.
IT SENT DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
PRESS POODLES INTO THE
STRATOSPHERE.
>> IT DISINTEGRATES AT THE VERY
CORE OF WHAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS
ABOUT.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO IS NOT
PLAYING ON AMERICA'S TEAM.
>> CONFESSING HIS IMMORALITY,
HIS CORRUPTION, HIS THUGGISH AND
ASH.
>> ACCEPTING ASSISTANCE FROM A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER LIKE
RUSSIA IS TREASONOUS BEHAVIOR.
>> Laura: FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE, TREASONOUS,
DEMOCRACY IN PERIL, OH MY!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
SUSAN RICE, THAT WAS A GREAT
ONE, SAYING HER POP UP IN THAT
MONTAGE.
APPARENTLY, WE ARE TO BELIEVE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WHAT
HE SAID IN ORDER TO, WHAT,
INVITE ON CAMERA FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP HIM WIN
REELECTION?
AGAIN, ALL IN PLAIN SIGHT?
I'M NOT SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD'VE MAY BE
HANDLED THE QUESTION SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTLY, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD'VE.
BUT LET'S NOT BE FOOLISH OVER
THE DEMOCRATS SUPPOSE A CONCERT
OF A FOREIGN INTERFERENCE IN
AMERICA'S BUSINESS.
FIRST OFF, IT WAS
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
ITSELF THAT PAID FOR THAT PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER HAWKED BY FORMER
BRITISH AM I SIX OFFICER
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THIS WAS ALL FILTERED THROUGH
THE SLEAZY RESEARCH FIRM, FUSON
DPS, RUN BY THE EVER SHADY
SIMPSON.
YOU MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN THAT
NELLIE OHR, THE WIFE OF DOJ
BRUCE OHR WORKED AT FUSION AND
MET WITH TRUMP DOSSIER AUTHOR
AND FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THE DAY
BEFORE THE FBI LAUNCH.
SO, WHERE WAS CONGRESSMAN
NADLER'S OUTRAGE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT ANY OF THIS
MEANS, IT MAY BE PUBLIC
RELATIONS, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: AND WHY NO
NANCY PELOSI PRESS CONFERENCE,
DEMANDING TO KNOW WHAT OBAMA
OFFICIALS KNEW AND WHEN THEY
KNEW IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS,
WHAT ARE YOU REFERENCING?
>> Laura: THIS WAS RUSSIA
MAKING SALACIOUS CLAIMS ABOUT AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
IN THE HEAT OF A VERY
CONTENTIOUS CAMPAIGN.
NOW, I WOULD ARGUE THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS ALWAYS BEEN
VERY OPEN ABOUT HIS DESIRE TO
PLAY HARDBALL POLITICS TO WIN,
YOU SAW THAT ON CAMERA, BUT THE
CLINTON TEAM WAS ALWAYS IN
CONCEALMENT MODE.
THEY WERE AIDED AND ABETTED BY
AN OBAMA DOJ DEEP STATE THAT WAS
DESPERATE TO SEE TO IT THAT
TRUMP WAS DEFEATED.
THEN AFTER HE WON, THAT HE WAS
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
ALL THE FEIGNED OUTRAGE FROM
DEMOCRATS OVER FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE, IT ALSO MADE ME
THINK OF SOMETHING ELSE.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU HEARD
DEMOCRATS COMPLAIN ABOUT WHAT
THE CHINESE HAVE BEEN UP TO HERE
IN AMERICA?
>> AS OF THE U.S. SCRAMBLES TO
LEARN THE EXTENT OF A MASSIVE
THEFT OF PERSONNEL RECORDS SAID
TO HAVE BEEN STOLEN BY CHINA,
NBC NEWS HAS OBTAINED A
CLASSIFIED GOVERNMENT REPORT
THAT SHOWS A REMARKABLY
PERVASIVE REACH OF CHINESE CYBER
SPYING NATIONWIDE.
THIS NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY
MAP SHOWS A RED DOT FOR EVERY
SUCCESSFUL COMPUTER INTRUSION BY
CHINA OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
NEARLY 700 WITH COMPUTER ATTACKS
IN EVERY STATE.
>> Laura: I MEAN, THAT REPORT
WENT ON AND ON.
DOES THAT LOOK A LITTLE MORE
PERVASIVE THAN ALL THE CLAIMS OF
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE AND
MEDDLING FROM SOME FACEBOOK
HACKERS IN BASEMENTS IN RUSSIA?
YOU BET IT DOES.
THAT REPORT DOESN'T EVEN ADDRESS
MASSIVE EFFORTS BY THE CHINESE
TO STEAL ARE VERY SENSITIVE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY, OR
INFILTRATE AMERICA'S PREMIER
RESEARCH UNIVERSITY.
THE DEMOCRATS TO DEMAND
RETALIATION, OR HOLD ENDLESS
HEARINGS AFTER CHINA STOLE ALL
THOSE PERSONNEL FILES CUSTOMER
FROM THE OFFICE OF PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT?
THIS ALL SHOWS US THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT FOREIGN COUNTRIES MEDDLING
IN OUR AFFAIRS, THEY JUST SAW
THIS YESTERDAY AS A CONVENIENT
WAY TO RESURRECT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, AND MAYBE EVEN
PUSH THEIR LEADERSHIP TO TAKE UP
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS ONCE AND
FOR ALL.
AND MAY BE, IN AN ODD WAY, THIS
KIND OF ILL-ADVISED INTERVIEWS
WITH GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS WILL
END UP FORCING THE DEMOCRATS
INTO THE CORN OF THE
NANCY PELOSI HOPED TO AVOID